the west has a problem with muslims
living in their midst
if you ask westerners in polls islam is
the faith that they would least like
their neighbours to belong to
and they'd least like their children to
marry into it's not the details of the
quran that bother people
it's fear of terrorism what a lot of
people haven't noticed is that islam
itself
is evolving in europe evolving into a
more western if you like
form
in europe the number of jihadist
terrorist attacks has fallen by 9
10 since 2015 but still
any murder is one too many and the
pictures of people having their heads
cut off by islamic state in syria and
iraq
are seared onto people's brains there's
a great worry that some of the fighters
who left europe and went
to islamic state in syria and iraq might
come back to europe and wreak havoc
there
western governments have responded in
two ways firstly by trying to catch
terrorists directly
and secondly and more controversially by
trying to curb islam itself
we see this in donald trump's travel ban
on travelers from some muslim countries
and in efforts by governments in places
like france to restrict displays of
islamic piety in public
by banning the burqa
the first generation of modern muslims
to move to europe
didn't know how long they were going to
stay and didn't tend to get too involved
in the local culture
for religious guidance they depended on
imams usually from the countries that
they came from
that changed with the second generation
who
spoke the local languages extremely well
and had no illusions that they were ever
going anywhere else
but felt slightly alienated from their
parents foreign religious influence
and also from the societies that they
were living in a few of these people
became so alienated that they turned to
terrorism the third generation of
muslims in europe appeared to have fewer
hang-ups than the previous ones
they're culturally more assimilated
they're much more liberal than the
earlier generations on questions about
things
like homosexuality or pre-marital sex
they're creating a new kind of islam
which in many ways is more liberal
half the muslim students in the united
states admit to having had premarital
sex
something that in countries that many of
them came from would carry a death
penalty
how can western governments encourage
the integration of muslims
the first thing is that they have to be
very strict about the real crimes being
committed
by the few they have to be tough on
catching terrorists
and tough on sending them to prison what
they should not do
is attempt to meddle with the faith
itself that's something governments are
not very good at
and it's evolving anyway without
official interference
once you start having things like burqa
bans and state-sponsored mosques
and public funding for the right kind of
preacher you risk creating a backlash
and further alienation
as people realize that newcomers
cultures are not set in stone
and the way that they interpret their
religion doesn't necessarily mean
they're not going to get on with their
neighbors
people become more accepting that's
probably why for example
london the biggest city in europe now
has a muslim mayor
rotterdam the biggest port in europe
also has a muslim mayor
and why two muslim women were elected to
the united states congress this year
one of them veiled islam has long and
frankly
under-appreciated history in the west
muslims have governed parts of europe
for 13 centuries
they helped rekindle the renaissance and
if today
the new slightly more liberal form of
islam that we see flourishing in the
west continues to
do so it could serve as an example for
muslims in other parts of the world